Hey look here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today we're
exterminating mice
[Music]
all right it is Thanksgiving Day I'm
here with my boy Nathan Tommy
my nephew Calvin and my niece Lucy here
and it is Thanksgiving week
unfortunately we had a mouse incident
yep
I was cooking Thanksgiving dinner and
one of our little grand friends ran
right under my feet rodents of unusual
size I don't think they exist never had
that happen before it's not happening
again visually at night we have been
hearing scurrying up in the crawl space
above the garage so we got a problem it
just recently got cold you'll see this
happen a lot and each year we have a
problem with mice in the garage right
when it gets cold all those mice and
then breathing out in the woods happily
all summer long
suddenly realize it sucks to be outside
in the wintertime and so they come into
our home and they can cause a lot of
problems
first off the number one carrier of Lyme
disease is mice and squirrels not deer
so when you get Lyme disease from ticks
it's usually because the ticks were
biting on mice and squirrels hunt a
virus and other diseases can come from
they also to up the house and if they
chew up the electrical wiring you can
start a fire and it's just really gross
and creeps my wife out which is the
number one reason why we are going to be
exterminating you feel ways to clean
your toes oh geez they're everywhere so
we went down to Walmart and we bought
all these traps for like twenty eight of
these little plastic wooden mouse traps
is like 14 bucks for 28 of them to get
two of these fancy traps where you don't
have to see the dead mouse this was 10
bucks for just two of them so hard to
beat the classic mouse trap now you can
buy poison but the problem with poison
is then you have all these sick dead
mice rotting away up in your
in your house so it's really hard to
beat cheap plastic wooden traps and fur
and for bait we're going to use peanut
butter which is the best mouse bait ever
so you guys ready to start beating up
some traps open up open up these mouse
traps right here can you open them up
[Music]
alright guys here we go we've got all of
our traps ready to go we need to put
peanut butter on each one so let me show
you how to do it so take a little peanut
butter on the knife
just a little bit okay and we just go
like that
okay see just like that you get it only
on the metal part nothing else though
just like just like that okay you don't
want it anywhere else not on the wood
not anything else just right like that
you guys go ahead
here's four knives are you guys please
take a knife and start helping me put
peanut butter good job Jason yeah that's
not too bad just on the tip of the
middle part right okay that's it yeah so
the reason why you put the peanut butter
only here is if you put peanut butter
anywhere else the mouse will start
licking it and then they'll set the trap
off and it won't get them so you want it
only here so that their head is right
here where the trap goes on I need a way
to to carry them okay that's about half
of them yeah it should be good no no
we're good we're good I'll come back for
more here all right so check out my
garage is it any shock that we get mice
in here I mean look at this place
yeah so cleaning up would be really
helpful but killing the mice is quicker
all right time to get up in the crawl
space one year I did this and I can't
find a rat snake up there
so this is usually where I come to get
them you can see about half my traps
from a year ago still aren't sprung and
they're still baited with peanut butter
so that means there are not a lot of
mice here this is not where our problem
is coming from right here this is mouse
poop that's what it looks like the size
of my finger right there a little
cylindrical piece of poop it's a pretty
old one itself I don't feel there's been
icing here for a while so here's the old
hole where the mice used to get into our
house you can see I filled it up with
the yellow foam and looked underneath it
on the little 2x4
underneath the hole how it's discolored
from hundreds of mice jumping in and out
of the hole and peeing right there you
can see that's how they used to get into
the house but that hole still sealed up
so they're getting in some other way
darn I gotta find it one of my traps was
successful see a little mouse skull
ribcage and everything yep there's one
of them there's another one of a little
skull in it alright so we're gonna sit
set an extra trapper tooth all the way
up here might as well not like we have a
shortage of traps all right so there we
go
[Music]
yeah peanut butter got on the trigger
made it slick so all right I got forward
trap set here in the crawl space above
the garage I'm gonna go get in the crawl
space above the house to see if we can't
figure out what's going on okay first
thing to do
inspect the top of the board yeah as a
mouse crap there it's a mouse crap there
not a time this is our attic see it's
got full of insulation here try not to
step in between the joists and end up my
demise you know I'm not seeing any signs
of mice being digging in the insulation
a few poops but they could be pretty old
yeah we'll see what happens
I'll throw some traps around the attics
done now we need to do the garage so I'm
gonna put a few traps up on the shelves
in the corners or I keep my car babe
I've got lots traps we're gonna spread
out the luf important part is to
remember where you put all the traps so
you don't accidentally find them with
your fingers you know months later so
now I need to set some traps inside but
we've got a two year old likes to touch
things so we need a spot where he won't
get his fingers snap
yes is where the mouse ran out from
under so I'm gonna put a trap in there
[Music]
[Music]
okay over the 28 traps we had we used a
little more than half of them so about
15 16 traps set out I'll check them
tomorrow morning and see what happens
hey guys you want to check the
mousetraps okay let's let's see what we
got here let's see what we got okay
I see something don't reach Endor today
that one of the traps one of the traps
is still good hold on a second let's see
hold on hold on let's see if this is the
same one that ran across my feet when I
was making Thanksgiving dinner that
matches it's him it's him I recognize
that face anywhere oh yeah oh okay there
we go
did its job just like it should now this
is the number one advantage to buying
cheap mousetraps you throw boy no
messing with demise okay so here we are
in the garage we're gonna check these
traps to see if we got anything no no
yeah no mice in the garage
interesting
all right no mice up there that's a good
sign
I'm here in the Attic above our bedrooms
and all five traps are untouched so
that's a good time well this is good
news we put out 1518 traps and only
caught one Mouse so that leads me to
believe that that mouse I saw in the
kitchen might have just been a lone wolf
operative as opposed to a part of a
bigger terror cell so we can hopefully
get them all out so I'm gonna replace
the trap in the kitchen and I'm gonna
keep checking these traps for about a
week or so I don't see anything after a
week means we probably got them all so
see how it goes well guys it's been a
week and no more mice I haven't caught
any more mice in the Attic above the
garage in the garage in the kitchen so I
think we got off lucky I think that
Mouse was a lone wolf operator instead
of part of a bigger problem so good news
there well I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you'd like to see more videos
from the outdoor boys YouTube channel
don't forget to click Subscribe we put
out new videos every week thanks for
watching guys